lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh you keep saying let's start and then
we're not starting but did you mean it
this time yeah oh okay so and like uh
it's okay everything's good but you
you look good today oh you say like i
don't actually usually no i i um you
know it's never a competition but you
look better than me today and it's fine
well why are you wearing your sunglasses
we talked about this and how i don't
like it well yeah but my my eyes are
because you look bad sometimes make me
seem like i'm ugly
that just means you're ugly no if you're
a person that says my eyes make me see
you know it's like i'm ugly you're ugly
you know what's cool about it is my my
um my eyebrows are above my my
sunglasses i didn't realize that a lot
of people's eyebrows go behind their
sunglasses but when you have eyebrows
that go above your sunglasses
you get like all sorts of
extra cool points i think like jack
nicholson
i was gonna say jack nicholson is the
one that i think of yeah
uh what do you mean extra points
uh extra points are extra cool points
who gives them where do you keep them
what are you doing these are not
tangible dudes okay
i came to here right now and there's a
[ __ ] silver dollar right here 50 cent
because you're
above your sunglasses you know what i
don't like is when [ __ ] guys
talk about 50 cent the rapper and they
say 50 cent why do they do that why do
white guys like with [ __ ] button
downs do that i don't know because they
think it's [ __ ] funny i guess no i
think sometimes think they think that
that's what it is it's it's it's uh
mildly racist
if they think it's what it is then yeah
it is yeah actually you guys like
fitty's i'm a 50 cent i like 50 cent you
know those guys that like barbecues with
open toe [ __ ] sandals they all always
have uh button-down shirts yeah that are
blue a shade of blue yeah
one shade of blue or another yeah no
matter what yeah i know yeah oh you
already knew yeah then forgive me for
[ __ ] they get pink when they drink
yeah definitely they get like lobstery
yeah yeah yeah for sure [ __ ] yeah it's
because they're probably already a
little sunburned from like yeah from
being out on a boat that shitty vacation
there oh dude that and they got that
[ __ ] stale beer sting you know we
went to high school with so many of
those guys i know that's why i know
about the 50 cent thing because they say
50 cent okay so but their dads say it
mostly their dad said well not anymore a
lot of them are dead and some of them
are 75 but
downer
well the whole thing is a downer dude 50
cent yeah that's a downer for sure
that's like calling snoop dogg's snooty
dog for no reason it's not a dog
it's not his name yeah it's not or tupac
tupac
oh you know about the [ __ ] my story
about that right no well yeah what is it
i was at the remember the warehouse the
[ __ ] oh my god yeah okay so i was at
uh the the cd store the warehouse it's
like sam goody back yeah
well sam goody's back in the day isn't
it
you're saying that's what i'm saying
that was like sam goody both of them
were back in there yes yes yes okay uh
but obviously they're both closed up not
because who the [ __ ] is cds anyway
uh i was in the aisle that i was always
in back then the hip hop rap aisle
looking for new [ __ ] yeah and some
little kid like when i say little i mean
like six maybe yeah he's running up and
down the aisles and the all eyes on me
was on display
and uh he's like mommy mommy mommy i
want this one i want this one i want
this one and his mom comes over and she
looks at it and it's a little bit more
expensive than the other ones because
it's it's yeah it's it's a double disc
or whatever and she and and
and she looks at it and she says oh no
honey we can't get that one that's a two
pack yes i remember that because it said
tupac yes
i remember it and what a [ __ ] idiot
she was yeah it's not when you say like
do you remember that well you remember
the tupac story you can't that's not
like the tupac story i didn't say that
did i you said remember that what
happened with me with the tupac story i
see you cd story yes i don't think you
did that was a yes
because we weren't talking about cds
we're talking about
we'll see who's right
okay yeah sure fine we can go back in
time and look at it too
but it's all good and i think i look
actually okay you look good okay well i
get insecure you look funky
i talked about that on my podcast depart
actually let me talk about dates before
we even do that oops i have to
um
well my my dad about dad said you look
funky yeah that's what i was really
because we were go we were in italy and
we were going to dinner and we made a
reservation and then matt dressed up and
i dressed up and when he walked through
his hotel door he was like oh matt you
look great and then i walked through and
he said oh chris you look funky and we
were like oh wow hates it so clear he
just didn't like what you were wearing
absolutely hate it and on the spot
wanted to say something not mean i
actually remember what i was wearing it
was funky and not good no it wasn't it
was a long sleeved v-neck
um that sounds terrible but it wasn't
though but it was okay but it was you're
gonna say it was like it was like green
it was like not it was like kind of
bright green it wasn't neon green but it
was bright green okay uh and then i had
rose tinted glasses so i guess i looked
a little funky yeah it sounds but i feel
like i looked good but he was like chris
you look funky and i never forgot it so
that's cool how i how it makes me feel
bad um so he [ __ ] up your life yeah
well
isn't that what parents do yes isn't
that what parents do yeah so i'm going
to be in atlanta on september 9th
washington dc september 10th
stockton oakland
peoria rockford raleigh uh october 21st
denver
colorado november 5th
boston and cheyenne boston november 12th
cheyenne wyoming and then jacksonville
florida december 3rd crystallia.com go
get tickets and more
um so yeah tickets are out there now and
uh i appreciate you guys uh coming and
seeing me we're starting in september i
did a phoenix date you know what i mean
and uh well i do know what you mean but
you shouldn't do you know what i mean
because it was in insanely not complex
50 cent
okay i did a phoenix date tourettes
all right so um
let's do it you want to do the first one
first devices yeah i'm going to get my
hood on for that yeah you don't need a
hood for that but i want to
okay let's go
what's up chris what's up matt my name
is brett and first of all thank you guys
so much for doing this podcast i know
everybody's been thanking you but nobody
can really thank you enough so thank you
for doing this i have two questions for
you guys actually if you want to stop
after the first
i can't do anything about that it's free
conch but my first one is in a few weeks
after i graduate i'm moving down to
atlanta i got my dream job i seriously
can't wait to start i'm so excited but
the problem is i know nobody in the
entire state of georgia
so i guess what i'm asking you guys is
what are some tips or advice you have
for me to organically meet people who
aren't [ __ ] weirdos really also side
note chris coming to see you september
9th in atlanta can't wait there you go
and my second question is the church of
k was matt's first episode on
congratulations do you guys still use k
to help you because
i've gotten my entire family and friend
group to use the term k
whenever somebody says something so let
me know love you both thanks so much
let's get one of those spinny hats on
with the fan
look at the propeller he's a wise person
he's just floating a little bit
yeah um i invented k okay so
of course i still say it yeah uh have
you backed off a little bit though on it
uh
yeah you know i backed off we grow you
know what i mean well only with people
who think it's some kind of insult which
bothers me to no end
that's like they'll be like oh you oh
you kid me as if it's like an affront to
them no no and i try to tell people it's
[ __ ] for me yeah [ __ ] you and then i
am insulting them so it makes the whole
thing [ __ ] point oh right yeah
sometimes i'll do it under my breath it
really is just for me so under my breath
yeah right people don't hurt i hear you
do it i hear you do it sometimes i do
you throw out a little bit okay
sometimes
so you do still use it i don't really
use it that much yeah you never did it
wasn't really uh doing karate never
really i'll just go ahead i'll do that
more yeah yeah right but you'll do it
quiet under your breath sometimes too
i'll hear you doing it yeah
yeah um you think i do a key eye like a
karate ki what the [ __ ] is a key eye
height
sit we should just do that what's that
one
that's what it's called
really yeah
yeah that's what it's called okay it
might be a japanese word anyway the
first question was how do you uh meet
people you gotta do it organically
otherwise you're gonna be crazy people
look everybody's crazy anyway but fan
out dude i think we should go back to
the old ways like [ __ ] the internet [ __ ]
hinge [ __ ] whatever it is you know what
i mean the the the instagram and the
online shits dude and go way back go way
back into
make flyers like flyers have a head shot
do a bow and say milady yeah stick out
your hand lady would you like to be a
friend no no no um
fan out get get head shots small cards
like you're a model and go you know what
i mean
nice guy here get your friend
friendship for sale uh but no you know
don't sell it but like get your friend
here
uh new fresh face in the area you will
meet the [ __ ] worst people that way i
would be me i'd be i'd come right up to
you and be like oh you want to be
friends no you would not although i do
make sure you're just [ __ ] friends i
know in the history of the [ __ ] world
get your friend here oh dude that's a
terrible idea but what you should free
friend okay
is you just
something that is actually a forgotten
a lost art even though i hate when
people say that yeah is making friends
in real life i've talked to people in
l.a we're like i don't know you can't
even approach
like guy friends or like i can't even
approach a woman in real life it's like
it's like too forward it's like creepy
and yeah like really that's the rules
now i didn't [ __ ] realize that but i
think for most people
certainly outside of la i'm assuming in
atlanta as well
it's like a refreshing thing when people
come up and talk to you and just sort of
like get to know you not like a [ __ ]
weirdo yeah like what's your favorite
color
you know don't know that's pretty cool
but like if you see it like the kind of
person that you want to know yeah just
[ __ ] say something that gets you in
there you know yeah and sometimes
they'll be like ah because they want to
meet someone new but whatever [ __ ]
them you're never going to see him again
friend you're talking about uh
friendship straight up like yes like not
even like dating yeah i mean
yeah yeah yeah hmm it's tough to meet
people organically no one has friends
anymore that's true if no one has
friends anymore that means everyone
wants friends so that means everybody's
ready to make friends so if you're the
[ __ ] person that is gonna have the
balls to go do it then that's good just
go [ __ ] do it he seems like he's yeah
he's got the courage do people want to
make friends still you think well no
what i know is they don't have them yeah
they should want to make them but i
don't know if they do but they should
because we need people people need
people people need that's what he's
saying i wonder where he's coming from
but you know what also don't push it you
know what i'm talking about like it'll
happen he's a [ __ ] nice dude he's a
regular guy seems like in a good way
he'll be in atlanta atlanta's great dude
atlanta's really great atlanta people
are [ __ ] nice people in the south are
nicey [ __ ] you know is that right yeah
dude go to the mall in atlanta go to the
mall you will see
the brightest colors and the biggest
asses oh and so many so many dudes that
laugh like this
like in atlanta it's insane dude
so many hats
not just with a regular brim like this
but hat psycho
dude when you go to atlanta it's pretty
much the kentucky derby oh just non-stop
yeah it's just non-stop you'll be in an
elevator and you'll be like is there a
horse race in here yeah it's unreal dude
the shortest horse face ever just
in there just obviously you if you're an
elevator without people with the hats on
you yeah yeah yeah like yeah yeah dude i
mean it's it's absolutely insane atlanta
is is atlanta is insane dude i've only
been to atlanta twice very briefly both
times really can't speak to atlanta yeah
why because you got you're only gonna
for how long
well i went for a wedding both times i
was there for like three days tops both
times oh yeah weddings it doesn't count
if you've been somewhere for a wedding
because you gotta like focus on the
couple and [ __ ] they're being so rude
about it so i hated it i hated the
experience i had yeah i can't say i
hated atlanta because i'm not really
there yeah yeah over what i'm saying
because i haven't said it yeah you know
what i'm saying yeah yeah okay you're
doing it okay all right well let's do
another one we gave him good advice yeah
what about the workplace i mean
yeah well we don't know what he's doing
depends on what he does i mean you're
going to make friends in the workplace
if you don't make friends in the
workplace you're a huge loser like if
you're if you don't make friends with
you like people who who leave work and
don't have friends there
you're a huge loser unless you're yeah
unless you're like a [ __ ] postmates
guy then it's creepy if he's going to do
post base move to atlanta do postmates
and then he's like hey your order's on
the way and then they drop it off and
the guy opens the door and he's just
like
what's your favorite color like
one time i had a postmate actually try
to make friends with me at my door yeah
and he was like asking me about where i
live and he like could see past me a
little bit and he's like oh what's it
like in there these kinds of places
yeah that's crazy should we turn the air
down yeah um dude i had a postmates guy
once show up dropped the food off and
then one time weeks later uh all of a
sudden there was a head shot of the
postmates guy on my kitchen island table
oh yeah you remember that yeah yeah yeah
dude how did you get in how'd it get in
there that's no good kristen didn't know
how it got there it was so weird i hope
that it was just like
right somebody that came in that was
like oh yeah you had this at your door
but i still don't know what the [ __ ]
had to do the problem is is that they
never
they will never not know where you live
henceforth i know so like there's a
weird i know
thing like i don't want to leave uh too
much of a shitty review because what if
it turns into like the cable guy i know
taxi driver kind of situation you know
yeah balancing these people is very very
hard you know what i mean yeah because
there are people out there that are
crazy and it's just hard to balance
these people you know yeah yeah um so
yeah
i don't know but it's workplaces if you
you gotta make friends in workplace
that's probably the number one place at
least in the beginning if you're moving
for work great make friends you know be
super nice he's nice wear my merch
connect on people you know what i mean
oh you you also know are you gonna go
see him in atlanta september 9th i mean
so [ __ ] self-centered but you can
though yeah but just simply can yeah
count on you to recommend the way to
meet people is to bring you up well or
let's go travel to dc this september
10th yeah yeah i'll be there all right
so anyway plug in yourself so [ __ ]
hard
do another one yeah
[Music]
hey man chris my name is cody i live in
massachusetts and i'm calling with some
career questions so i've been working as
an engineer for five years now and i
think like a lot of people my age i
don't necessarily love what i do there
are definitely some hobbies i partake in
that i think would make a better
fulfilling career for me
um but when having a full-time job and
stable income you create all these
excuses for yourself all these
roadblocks that stop you from really
going for something you might love
because it might affect your life so the
advice i'm looking for is um how can you
get over
limits you put on yourself how can you
really just go for something that you
love and not worry about the outcome not
be scared of the outcome not strive for
perfection right away
um let me know what you guys think
thanks
uh i have i have the best of he's
wearing a boxing robe what was that yeah
he's getting out of his car to do a uh
prize fight
anyway ding ding anyway thanks a lot
lifeline ding ding ding in this corner
guy from subaru
um no i've really good advice for this
and i haven't been able to use this
advice yet but it's it's good advice for
a lot of scenarios and the advice is
you're gonna [ __ ] die
what you're gonna not advise
you're going to die and you're going to
die pretty [ __ ] soon i mean according
to the whole world but also life's
really long blip
of a blip of a blip of a blip you are
nothing you are utterly insignificant if
you don't do the [ __ ] you want to be
doing now
you don't
what money you'll depress tyson dude
that's so
[ __ ] you are nothing you are you will
die you billions and billions of blips
and you're one of them and you suck and
you will die yeah yeah so so so so so so
sad no it's not dude it's the most
freeing [ __ ] ever it frees you oh it's
freeing it raise you up to be like well
what the [ __ ] am i gonna what i'm gonna
be like embarrassed about not being
perfect at the thing i wanna do so bad
i'm gonna like my friends are gonna
think i'm stupid who the [ __ ] cares
they're gonna die too yeah also you sent
a video in here dude
that's
embarrassing it's more embarrassing than
[ __ ] not doing what you want to do in
your life be scared dude that fear makes
you real do you understand that oh my
god you rose to that level yeah nowhere
no i did but i found it within me so if
i found it within me he could find it
within him right okay dude the guy's the
kind of guy wears a boxing robe in a
subaru he was wearing a boxing ring go
out and do your [ __ ] thing baby yeah
listen to [ __ ] luke bryan
that song i'm doing my thing i'm just
doing my thing yeah it's general
it's really general because it needs to
be general because it needs to hit a lot
of people because luke bryant is on the
level on that wavelength and get on it
dude
who's that
luke bryant yeah
he's a country singer he's the biggest
country singer oh okay yeah don't know i
mean he's the biggest character he has a
song that says just doing my thing yeah
just general but also dude yeah it's for
guys like you dude you're gonna [ __ ]
die
and do you want to die having not done
the [ __ ] you wanna do
or do you wanna die
having done the [ __ ] you wanna do
it's gonna be a blip no matter what make
it a [ __ ] fun blip make it a fun
blip neil depressed tyson make it a fun
blip the worst [ __ ] captain in a
submarine
make it
a fun
blip
thank you okay uh cool make it a fun
blip i think uh you got it dude fear
means you're real
fear is a gift
fear is something that you can use to
propel yourself into the abyss of the
unknown
okay the abyss of the unknown is a gift
okay okay get out there and swim in it
okay and find your way finding your way
is a gift oh wow okay you've got three
gifts so many gifts christmas santa
you've got three gifts for you
awaiting do you want those gifts wow or
are you a [ __ ] in a boxing robe in a
subaru okay okay you're welcome
i gave you a gift okay that's your first
gift you gave him three gifts well i
gave him one and now he's got three
waiting you want to unwrap them okay
that's on you if you don't
sit in that subaru baby
make it a fun blip you're gonna die
anyway all right there we go all right
what's next
she got the shirt so
what do you guys think about when for
example
somebody opens a door for you and you
say thank you yeah
and they don't say anything back
and like not not just they don't say
anything back but they don't even give
you
a head nod or like make eye contact with
you to acknowledge that you've just said
thank you
like
that [ __ ] makes me
brm oh we know and i have to try so hard
not to get an attitude about it
but then other times i'm like okay maybe
i need to just chill out like they're
doing me the favor
whatever no big deal and other times i'm
like [ __ ] that how hard is it to just
say you're welcome or anything like why
are you being [ __ ] rude
anyways just want to see what you guys
think about it
dude
it's okay i got one further though
you people you open the door she says
you open the purse there are people over
the door for you that's nice yes then
you say thank you some people would be
like that's the end of the exchange they
would be like you open the door for me i
reciprocated that's our that's the end
here okay but i've got one further dude
i know what you're gonna say yeah
sometimes you open the door for people
they just walk right through like
they're the [ __ ] king of starbucks
yeah nothing hey dude
nothing makes me more [ __ ] furious
in terms of like a an an everyday
scenario it's awful all you got to do
all you got to do is just look at me
nod smile say thanks do [ __ ] anything
to acknowledge what i just [ __ ] did
it's not like i did something great but
like how miserable are you [ __ ]
it's easier to just say thanks than to
swallow it and be like [ __ ] this guy
yeah you have hate in your heart get rid
of it dude be free you know i've lived
in my life i've had hate in my heart you
got to let it go dude you got to just
say thank you they're doing something
nice if you don't that's on you that
[ __ ] turns into cancer that festers and
then one day
and it becomes chest cancer or whatever
it is dude cancer brain cancer and
aneurysm i think though for the for her
i think the advice is yeah
it's about not going
forward with your day in fury right and
i think the key to that is to recognize
that is a miserable [ __ ]
and they're doomed no matter what yeah
right i mean and it goes both ways if
you open the door for someone and they
don't even acknowledge it that is a
miserable [ __ ] yeah they're having a bad
blip they're not gonna have a fun blip
they're gonna have a bad [ __ ] blip
yeah
and that's that that is already enough
to to know to go forward with your day
to know well that person's [ __ ] anyway
hey just stop him oh right
whoa
yeah what's going on in your life man
what's going on here what's around here
what's going on here imagine if you did
that imagine if you did when someone
moved you said open the door they said
thank you and you stu
you said thank you and they don't say
anything and you go whoa
what's going on here yeah but you slide
in front of them yeah yeah yeah yeah
whoa yeah was it the end of the exchange
yeah
yeah that person would be so weirded out
yeah
but do that and then also this is a
great thing where you can implement a
spin move and walk out but i'm just
saying you knew that was coming at some
point yeah you could um yeah i've done
that multiple times a lot of times i say
a lot of times i go oh okay that's what
i do yeah i say oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah falling but yeah oh
yeah busting too early but yeah first
guy who busts in the origin
all right um
yeah i think that that's a it's a it's a
it's a
it's that's on the other person yeah but
yeah it is important to go forward with
your day not being so full of rage
though yeah you got to live with people
you got to let it go and you got and
people are in the world and they're
going to make you feel a certain way and
you got to just let it go it's really
[ __ ] hard trust me i get it i get it
yep
yeah [ __ ] on your side though [ __ ] him
though okay well
guys my name is lucas i'm in seattle
washington so happy i'm big fan of the
new show love what you guys are doing
um so i have a younger brother he's
always had this mentality that the world
is against him but he's still a
go-getter don't get me wrong but only to
the extent to where he feels comfortable
if he makes a big move he has to know
somebody there for him to actually
commit to something um
you know it's always kind of been a
drawback for him uh i was born and
raised in mississippi always hated it
out there
i worked hard to get where i'm at in
this world you know i'm happy i'm trying
to live life to the fullest because life
does in fact rip right yeah it does um
my brother calls me all the time he
complains like he hates his job he hates
where he's from
but he just won't do anything about it
you know i keep telling him he just
needs to take the plunge and just
leave and go somewhere but
like i said he's really uncomfortable
just leaving what he knows
any advice to kind of
give him the extra motivation to just
take the leap and just
grab life by the balls again
love the show guys um any advice would
be greatly appreciated thank you i know
it's tom okay them
next time he calls and complains i hate
my job i hate where i live tell him
you're gonna [ __ ] die okay this is
gonna die
and you're gonna [ __ ] die and it's
gonna be miserable okay because you
lived a miserable life in a miserable
place with a miserable job
get the [ __ ] out of there
you're gonna die
yeah but also if you say that too much
then the guy's gonna think yeah you're
right you're gonna die [ __ ] it i might
as well just stay here no this guy needs
to be scared is my point you got to
scare this guy out of complacency
and so you got to shake him up even more
aggressively you're going to [ __ ] die
okay it's
a bit much i think that maybe just
the realization of you're just going to
be stuck in the same place because also
go back to you're just a blip and if
he's just a blip then what's it matter
what he does right so you got to ride
that line of look dude this is your life
make the most of it come out why don't
you invite him to seattle
he lives in mississippi right is that
what he said he said he's from there i
don't know if he's okay well
his brother lives somewhere he doesn't
want to and he wants to move but yeah
dude the truth is he is going to die it
is scared to move and here's the other
thing too as a brother you can be
like look i don't want to hear about
this [ __ ] i made my move yeah i'm
happier now you don't like where you are
as a brother i don't want to be hearing
about this [ __ ] anymore now i have a bit
of a little bit of a bad brother if
that's what you do because you could be
an earpiece for the guy but also that
could be what he needs i mean dude this
guy could be literally addicted to his
life he could be addicted to where he
lives he could be addicted to that
[ __ ] small town in mississippi
wherever he is that he doesn't like and
if he is then he needs to hit [ __ ]
rock bottom and have his brother be like
look dude you're complaining too much
yeah this is [ __ ] yeah listen to you
you gotta leave i'm out of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh complainy relationship yeah
you make me miserable you're affecting
other people i live my life in seattle
it's beautiful it's bright it's sunny
it's not it rains but yeah you know what
i mean like
move yeah yeah get your life on track
baby yeah yeah
sell coke okay well no i mean just do
something different the thing about the
push weight is that it may be depressing
but you're [ __ ] lucky it's the least
likely [ __ ] ever dude so make the
[ __ ] most of it it's not about your
insignificance yeah it's about your
lucky as [ __ ] to get this minor blip
because most of everything is pure
[ __ ] darkness right so get the [ __ ]
out of that shitty ass [ __ ] job
do something else that is true it's not
like to work hard and make it you'll be
a success that's not necessarily [ __ ]
true yeah but you don't want us [ __ ]
sit away and wither away somewhere man
you can't do that [ __ ] i agree with that
stop letting him complain to you [ __ ]
that enough is enough if he could does
it that much it's not helping him
anymore it's it's just like a it's just
like a [ __ ] shoulder to cry and it
doesn't help i'd like to know how long
it's been because it's tough it's it's
tough dude it's a tough love is is like
a thing in theory that makes sense it's
not like you stopped talking i know yeah
right okay you're so talking like i
don't want to hear this [ __ ] anymore
yeah yeah either try to [ __ ] change
it or i don't want to hear it anymore
because what am i going to do i'm just
going to listen [ __ ] that
i gave you my advice now either take it
or don't but stop [ __ ] complaining
yeah
but is there a tender way to say that
stop complaining
i don't think you need to be tender
really it's his brother yeah but he
obviously cares about him it's not a
matter of that i guess so yeah
you don't have to always be [ __ ]
tender he'll get it
he'll if he explains it with his words
he can't just be like stop complaining
that would be good you know
oh look [ __ ] johnny depressed [ __ ]
head is calling again
johnny depressed [ __ ] head johnny
depressed head
um yeah i don't know it's [ __ ] sad
man that made me this reminds me of
people who speak your
and never [ __ ] take it
that's what it [ __ ] sounds like yeah
this guy's bitching and moaning about
his job about his life about his
whatever the [ __ ] and he never [ __ ]
changes it um it's the same [ __ ]
thing yeah you on the other end of it
you can change the at least the fact
that you're his like shoulder to cry and
when he's not going to do [ __ ] about it
anyway right
it can light a fire under someone's ass
and so i'm right you're gonna [ __ ]
die tell him next time he calls pick up
just say that first true
but
is it is the guy actually asking him for
advice or is he just trying to motivate
his brother unsolicited yeah he's asking
us what he can do yeah to help his
brother but he's not saying that his
brother is always calling him asking him
for advice and then no but i still think
he should say stop [ __ ] calling me
and [ __ ] complaining yeah that's what
you're saying that's your advice yeah
i'm saying is he is the brother even
complaining yes that's what he says yes
yes i mean guy [ __ ] has the videos on
his [ __ ] computer and looks at him
and screens him and then plays him again
here has no idea what the [ __ ] video
is about he's trying to sabotage us yeah
so i'm sorry so what's this video about
you [ __ ] put it in the goddamn
timeline
i i see a lot and i get them mixed up
he's so drunk right now um
i see a lot honestly and i get mixed up
man i wasn't sure if he's raised from
all right dude uh next one
well my question has to do with tattoos
i've got a couple and this is the only
one that people ever
make comments about well because you
understand why yeah maybe for good
reason i don't really think so but uh i
grew up in
tanzania uganda for most of my life and
that's why i got the tattoo and people
will make comments about it and
some people say that they don't think
that i should have it because oh wow uh
the way that i look
and um
i disagree with that i think
it's it's something that means a lot to
me so
uh let me know what you guys think um
chris i'm sorry i've got long hair and
no facial hair it's okay
i don't know i'll sense you at the end
about it well i mean it's not like he's
walking up to people and being like hey
oman yeah you know that's jamaican sorry
what's on his chest what oh yeah it's a
tattoo with an outline of africa it's
africa and he's super white he's not
just even white yeah he could just i
mean he's got like crazy there are white
people in africa south africa mainly
yeah right so well i mean you should
have got just south africa you could
also be like referring to like the
genesis of humanity it could be a lot of
things everybody's going to be the same
color at some point it's not out of line
to have that
like out of hand naturally it's not
[ __ ] up uh i think now is probably the
wrong time to have that but he probably
got it a while ago of course but on his
[ __ ] chest which he can wear shirts
over right didn't know like how often is
he around people with no [ __ ] shirt
on he just should have got it in the a
little bit over to his right and then he
would have been like [ __ ] africa man
the superhero just right across his
chest he could also just get the entire
globe mm-hmm you're saying that
yeah but that's bitching out to the vote
mob dude if he feels important about
being in africa he feels important about
being in africa i mean the guy could
have spent [ __ ] a wee you know what i
mean he's like this he's saying people
think he's a version of you know those
chicks that go to [ __ ] europe for
like two months and then come back and
they're like cheers mike yeah and you're
like god damn it dude
you ate a [ __ ] crumpet but if he
explains i'm from there
yeah i lived my entire life though that
should do it it's not out of line just
yeah again it's not out of line just
because you're white
if i got it that would be [ __ ]
suspect right you're actually from there
i think honestly go further and just get
jamaica on your forehead
so every country just every black is
predominantly black [ __ ] it dude well no
then then he would be out of line in the
wrong but this is what happens when i
say don't push me he's getting pushed
over dude he got something because it
feels nice to him and then people are
like you shouldn't have that that's
gonna push him over don't tell him what
to do he went he was in africa dude and
he [ __ ] grew up in tanzania isn't
that what he said yeah and so he [ __ ]
grew up there so he has something
important on his chest dude dude you got
to live with people yeah and this is the
dude that has the africa on his chest
but this is don't push him he'll get
jamaica on his forehead but you don't
change just because people don't like
the way you are it's just as bad as
trying to get rid of it i understand
don't go further you don't scale back
you just stay exactly how you are he
knows why he got it it wasn't a [ __ ]
[ __ ] up reason he's fine next time
somebody has some [ __ ] to say about
it just be like
what the [ __ ] i'm from there bye no yes
okay what's that whoa why do you have
africa on your chest
i'm from tread lightly dude i'll get
jamaica on my forehead no that's not
that's not it
no
also getting a tattoo on your forehead
is also never the solution i don't even
know what jamaica looks like like the
outline it would probably just look like
he'd look like gorbachev i'm not
surprised but yeah um i think that next
time somebody has something to say
explain that you're from there and if
they still has a [ __ ] problem [ __ ]
that person um
okay yeah i guess so i mean it's better
than getting jamaican on your [ __ ]
forehead also it's not a good one i know
that tattoo is so dark
but that tattoo every tattoo was dark no
no but he didn't use single needle i
think he was triple needle or whatever i
don't know what any of that means okay
anyway just looked like a regular tattoo
to me the
outline of africa yeah okay all right
next one
hey chris and matt um i have a question
kind of about
career advice
i didn't expect to be at the level that
i'm at with my career um i'm 30 and i'm
now working at my dream company and
doing my dream job and um i'm not sure
where to go from here i wasn't expecting
to be at this point at this point in my
life um and i've always kind of lived my
life
um hustling and you know constantly
working towards the next thing
and um and i'll be honest i haven't
really
won a lot in life and um this is the
first time that it genuinely feels like
all of my hard work
culminated into something
so
um
my manager's been asking me about um my
career goals and to be honest especially
over the past couple years i don't
dream of work anymore
um my career goals have completely
changed where i don't feel like i tie my
identity to my job anymore
and i'm not really sure where to go from
here
i want to keep doing great things and
keep moving forward and upward
but i don't want my career to be front
and center anymore
wow how do i decide on the next chapter
of my life
i've been spending a lot of time with my
hobbies and things that really make me
happy like traveling and things like
that
and it's been incredible
and that's the part of life that i
really want to do and i want my work to
be secondary
so how do i keep moving upwards with my
career
and how do i decide
the next thing thank you
i mean did she write that out she how
does she not stutter at all that was
unbelievable that's a good graduation
this is why she zoomed ahead in her
phone yeah dude she did what or what's
her job i i mean what she didn't say i
know uh storing acorns it was a chipmunk
there was no video by the way for people
who are just listening yeah there's no
video the thing about my job is you know
you can only store so many acorns and in
one day it's like how many acorns can i
store
so i'd like to hang out with alvin and
theodore a bit more and go and travel
places like another tree but
anyway
i mean it sounds like a typical
workaholics dilemma it's just you happen
to hit that wall a little earlier than
most people i mean she said she's 30.
that's [ __ ] that's really really
young for that yeah to hit the phase of
your career where you're like well i i'm
i've arrived at where i've always wanted
to be
and that does
even though it's like i think some
people would be like ah it's [ __ ] too
bad for you but like no it's all
relative and everything's [ __ ] up for
everybody but i think that
she's starting to [ __ ] figure it out
anyway yeah she's just like starting to
travel more starting to see what else is
out there i think that's the only just
keep going with that you'll find another
thing that you're passionate about the
problem is you've only been passionate
about work your whole life
and now you're starting to see well what
the [ __ ] could i possibly be passionate
about the answer is nothing but there's
stuff out there in the world i promise
you that yeah
look the grass is always greener right
and it sounds like she's struggling
about what she wants and what she has to
do and then what she wants to do that's
kind of what everybody feels in their
life unless they
really have some sort of come to jesus
moment and it's fine and it sounds like
you might be having one of those things
but also allow yourself not to worry
about it yeah allow yourself to just be
and do your job and you don't have to do
it forever you don't have to do it
forever that's the best thing about you
know it's not like you're in some
[ __ ] slave labor camp i don't think
so you know what i mean no i would
highly doubt that this is where she's
inspired to be here yeah i've got the
big the you know
the guy the big guy who has the airplane
the chipmunk whipping me and making me
store acorns whatever i don't know what
his name is i wish i didn't [ __ ] find
but i can't do the joke but like he um
yeah dude it's just like do your do your
do your job
until you don't want to do your job
anymore but also and also stack money
yeah and give yourself you could also
give yourself a deadline you could give
yourself a deadline and be like i'm
gonna work this job for another year
and see how happy i am yeah
but i think the bottom line is allow
yourself not to worry and just to be
yeah you're [ __ ] i'm smart you're
[ __ ] 30 dude you're fine
her yeah i'm obviously talking to you uh
because she's the one who called him
singing advice not you yeah um but she's
30 years old and is already out where
she wants to be that's crazy he's
[ __ ] sick you're not don't be in a
rush to do anything keep traveling keep
[ __ ] around sometimes when i when i'm
i fall into these like holes where like
i'll get interested in something and
then i'll
burn myself out on it learn everything
there is to learn about it and be like
yeah well now what do i do yeah and this
is outside of work it's just like pure
interest stuff but sometimes the way
i'll stumble on a new thing that i'm
interested in is i'll just be in a room
where there's like so usually it's
someone else's [ __ ] study or a place
where they keep their books their office
and i'll pull at random a book and i'll
make myself read it wow and it's not
that you're guaranteed to be interested
in that subject wow but just the fact
that it's something that you would never
normally read there will be something in
there that piques your interest and then
that thing will lead to another thing
that peaks your interest and that thing
will lead to another thing and i'm not
saying that that's the solution but
you're 30 and you [ __ ] arrived
do [ __ ] like that to just see what the
hell might be next because [ __ ] man like
i know you're probably sick of hearing
this but you're in a good position
at least acknowledge that
yeah and just take it easy on yourself
uh yeah take it easy on yourself is the
main thing i think also we don't know
what her job is if she's a [ __ ] i
mean this could be one of those things
like well what do you do well i buy
groceries at the grocery store and she's
like oh okay well then you just have
really really low yeah she did say she
has a manager
that's the only thing i could do yeah so
you're obviously not you know what i
mean you're not the best become the
manager first and then we'll talk yeah
because i'm the manager become the
manager and then we'll talk yeah yeah
what kind of [ __ ] low aspirations
yeah what's going on here what's going
on here yeah what's around here
okay
not bad
hey guys i just wanted to talk to you
about an issue i've had for a while now
longer than i care to admit
basically just to cut straight to the
chase i smoke too much weed it takes up
far too much of my time and money and i
could be using all of that way more
productively i'm just wondering if you
guys have ever dealt with any addictions
or you know just things that are
distracting you that you know aren't
good for you and how you've dealt with
it
life rips thanks
life does rip addiction sucks it's hard
addiction sucks but the thing about weed
we've talked about this a little bit but
i've known all different kinds of
potheads i've i've been one myself i
still smoke but i smoke a lot less than
i used to what do you smoke sticky icky
or loud
what do you smoke purple lurple i don't
know any of the things that you're
saying kush chocolate thai just smoke
marijuana oh wait
uh i eat it smoke it uh
chocolate we'll go with chocolate okay
chocolate time oh wait um but
i think that ganja the the kinds of
stoners that i've known
range from extremely
uh productive and you like can't even
tell that they're high yeah too like the
[ __ ] on the couch eating funyuns
all day playing mike tyson's punch out
until it's
the next day
you know never getting up still wearing
pajama pants yeah uh uh you know and and
and i i can't and that person would tell
you
weed does make them lazy but i know i
know people that it actually is the
opposite they can't really work unless
they smoke weed they can't operate
unless they smoke weed so it's like on
which one of those people are you this
guy must stop you stop first of all
second of all this guy doesn't seem like
a lazy [ __ ]
i'm sensing that there's clearly some
kind of problem now yeah like when he
smokes he must be a lazy [ __ ]
well the monetary thing is a big thing
right yeah he's spending a lot of money
also if he's high now i wouldn't be able
to tell dude exactly i mean if he's high
off that ganjo right now yes i'd have no
[ __ ] idea exactly so he seems like
he's a functioning [ __ ] weedaholic if
there even is one yeah
yeah so um addiction's tough man uh
you'd have to figure out the root of the
problem are you addicted to the drugs
are you addicted to uh some people are
addicted to the thrill you know what i
mean some people are addicted to acting
out some people are addicted to
different things so trying to figure out
what that is um would be beneficial
therapy would be beneficial um
it's really hard to struggle addiction
is always a struggle it's not something
you figure out and um you know you just
spend your life trying to but he seems
young enough with a good head on his
shoulder on his shoulders um
i don't know i think it's a tough it's a
tough thing it's weird too because weed
is one of those things that's like
benign you can get your i mean in
australia and i think it's like america
you can just get your card and just be
be high all the time everywhere as long
as you're not operating a [ __ ]
forklift you don't even need a card
anymore you don't oh yeah that's true
you just have to be a vase yeah but just
don't operate a forklift
and you're good but uh i think um what
the [ __ ] was i going to say
here's what i always say to people who
are like i smoked too much weed yeah
because i never had the problem of not
being able to stop right for at least a
few days i sometimes even at my peak of
smoking so much weed there would be days
where i would not smoke at all so it was
never an actual addiction but i would
smoke like a [ __ ] and get really
high throughout the course of many days
whether i was working or not i would say
first things first try to go two or
three days without doing it at all see
what happens if you have actual
withdrawals you probably have an actual
[ __ ] problem yeah uh but if you don't
your tolerance will actually go down and
that'll affect the economic angle the
financial angle right it won't be as
expensive weed tolerance fluctuates like
a [ __ ] if you stop for a week
one [ __ ]
one of those bong rips will get you high
off your [ __ ] ass yeah or hurry up
and hit your hot your rock bottom and
just start doing heroin right and start
dealing heroin and doing heroin yeah
getting high on your own supply hit the
rock bottom and then come clean you're
young enough to where you'll probably be
able to get out of it now we're not
licensed physicians or anything like
that or therapists yeah he knows that
based on the advice you just gave up but
honestly start selling heroin
that is
i think you sometimes achieved it you've
achieved the single worst piece of
advice in the history sometimes the only
way to solve a problem
is what what have we learned
is to create another problem okay but
not that problem deal heroin deal and do
heroin is the worst solution get your
heroin
the guy in atlanta with friends that's
a heroin free friend with a pound of
heroin that's how you can make [ __ ]
friends
one free friend
on one pound of heroin
hello what are you doing excuse me
hello
oh why are you english
when you do it um because it's an
old-timey thing to hawk stuff on the
street and everyone was english back
then
in the old times oh okay got it well
dude they weren't [ __ ] and even in
america they talked like that no they
did in movies they did those that like
uh mid-atlantic action
those movies that john malkovich is in
he does him and i do him dangerous
liaisons when he has a little wig with
the crowd whatever those [ __ ] old
wow the worst script of all time
hello i'm here for the meeting adjourned
let's get to the matter at hand they're
always got matters dude let's get to the
matter at hand
there it was a thing in the town square
that didn't go according to
john is not thing john excuse me paul
giamatti you really can't be ad-libbing
saying thing and also
two scenes ago you said okay and that
wasn't even in the vernacular
in
1779. dude you know what i [ __ ] hate
yep is when movies in that are spoken in
it's an english language right and they
take place in another country yep and
they use accents gladiator of that place
gladiator talk latin or i'm not well i'm
not watching just no no no speak english
without accents oh right right yeah say
dude honestly
a local accent i know it's already
[ __ ] in english i want it to be
all right what's up bro where are you
know what i mean well that's a little
far no i mean it dude julius caesar come
out and be like nah bro kill him
that'd be pretty sick actually send out
the [ __ ] lions dude i would watch the
[ __ ] of that [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
gladiator is just like are you not
entertained bro
what the [ __ ] man where my homies at
yeah
wow wow you should have been in that i
know
i know i don't like that thing why why
accents it's like such bull it's so
old-time [ __ ] it's just not
it's like that's not a good middle
ground there shouldn't there isn't a
middle there isn't a middle ground or
don't do it do it in the proper language
just do it in your normal voice i love
to russell crow when i saw gladiator
even back when it came out first when it
came out i was like that guy's going to
be a fat guy you knew that right oh you
knew russell crowe is going to be a fat
guy and now look at him man no no no
hate he's a great actor he's super
talented yeah and he's a dude so he
could probably wet it up no matter what
weight he is well yeah he's really
talented famous guy i never lack in that
department but he you knew
you knew he was just that's a guy that's
just so plump yeah he was like already
fat basically even though he was cut up
and no but the
the thing i want russell court to do and
uh weirdly enough i've been saying this
for years
and this is before he got fat
i want him to get fat
and play like a father of a child who's
got like a lot of like issues in their
life and i want him to like break down
crying in a couple scenes if he was a
really fat guy and broke down crying in
scenes he would win every award yeah
you're right you know what i mean
yeah you're right what's weird is i
didn't just think of that right now i've
been saying this for a long time that is
very weird yeah but isn't it true yeah
and he should have a button-down shirt
and his belly should come out of the
bottom when he's crying on the couch
when he sits the buttons come out a
little bit and his knees are higher than
his [ __ ] belly dude
right there dude the academy where city
party would show up right at the scene
and be like excuse me i need to and just
give it to him yeah it's true he would
be still getting his hair sometimes his
hair is long like wavy it would be that
big right in the middle in the middle
yeah yeah yeah
wow
yeah
is sydney portia dead right yeah i think
he's dead maybe i don't know if he died
or not but whatever i mean like
i think so he might have died if he died
it was in the last three years
sidney poitier huh that that last name
is so common oh he died dude he died
this year yeah but imagine meeting a guy
with a last name portier poitier it's
poitiers
sydney
what is that
we should give each other advice now
okay okay don't wear so many chains no
run your neck that's not really advice
well no no we need to ask each other
first
[ __ ] dick but i wanted to give that
advice for a while now all right well
you gave me that it's also not so many
it's two chains
it's like two chains well now you make
me feel bad no i'm not it's not feel bad
i feel fine dude i'm iced out oh good
okay all right i'll start okay jesus
christ i
am working out okay and i'm trying to
eat better okay and i have a hard time
staying within my discipline yeah right
so
i want to know if you guys have tricks
to
help yourselves do it's hard i do she
does i do i've never had that problem so
he does well what never had what problem
you don't never needed to work out yeah
why because i'm like [ __ ] ripped
obviously i'm not but like i never
really have gained weight why not why
have i not gained weight why have you
not why do you not work out it's good to
be active
oh i mean i'm not i would i would say
i'm particularly inactive but i never
ever ever like go to the gym every once
in a while i'll get on the [ __ ]
treadmill or i'll go for like a long
walk or something but i've never been
like a root regular working out person
how come
oh because i don't like it i don't like
doing it yeah um
and what was the last time you ran
oh actually kind of recently like maybe
two weeks ago you're like i robbed a
bank what about um was the last time you
jumped
jumped yeah
i mean just like
jumped jumped onto something
that's working out well no but it's
active
i don't know when the last time i jumped
on something was what was that somebody
did a push-up i mean what the [ __ ] kind
of questions was it last time you jumped
i'm asking dude uh
uh on the stand on the stand
i don't know did you kill her um so
look i think that um
you have to what i do is i don't [ __ ]
try to cut everything out and completely
go okay no carbs whatever the [ __ ]
people do you know what i mean but um i
make sure when the
to save i think this is actually really
good advice save the eating like [ __ ]
to only your cravings right like wait
till you crave the ice cream and then
eat the ice cream don't just mindlessly
do it really realize if you want to eat
it or not or if it's just a your board
thing that's a huge step for me because
in the day i don't get cravings until
until night but um
but but if you ask me do you want a
doughnut now i do want it but i'll be
like yeah but i only kind of want it
because it's here not because i crave it
so save your junk food until the
cravings that's step one and finding the
motivation to work out is really hard
sometimes but doing it as a routine is
best i used to always do it at 3 30 from
3 30 to like 4 30 or from four to five
you know and just [ __ ] doing it when
the sun's nice and i'm out there i'm
glistening and i'm sweating i do some
outside and i'm doing curls and my
shit's cascading down my chest and it's
getting bigger as this beef enough it's
getting harder the be for the sweat
beads to roll down because what happens
my chest gets elevated and i wanted to
get to the point where my chest gets so
elevated that the beads just kind of sit
there do you know what i mean dusting
just [ __ ] straight up disgusting
the slower the beads go down the hotter
your chest is popping out right
i don't know well i take your word for
it and that's disgusting
you might know but disgusting um so
that's getting into a system of working
out and only eating [ __ ] on the cravings
i think is the key and uh that's when
you can start and then once you start
seeing uh
um results
you're kind of off to the races dude
right once you start seeing results
because they say nothing
food doesn't taste nothing tastes better
than
skinny feel skinny feels and to those
people it's like i don't know dude i
don't know how many calzones you've
eaten but like
sometimes food is just so good right
once
uh but also you gotta you gotta see that
in the mirror you gotta see those
results and then you're like cool [ __ ]
them calzones yeah you know yeah yeah
that makes sense um
oh so insecure uh i think that um
i think that once i do start gaining
weight i'm gonna be a fat fat fat [ __ ]
you know i actually was driving here
today thinking like dude what what is
the decision like
because here's the thing for me i i look
you know i feel like i look fine i'm i'm
fit enough but like i feel like
dear if i was gaining weight i would
have a decision to make and the decision
isn't to start working out necessarily
it could be but some people i feel like
i would be like you know what i'm gonna
be a fat guy yeah you know what i mean
yeah actually check this out dude
i choose to be a fat guy [ __ ] it yeah
because some people are just fat because
they don't work out and some people
could just be like you know what i
kind of don't mind being fat and i don't
need to work out so i'm choosing to be
[ __ ] lumpy where girls don't like
okay
yeah well so what you're saying what
what is that like you're wondering what
yeah what is it like to actually be like
because i think that that would be my
choice i'd be like i'd be a fat guy [ __ ]
it i'm my personality's hot enough to
where i can afford to be you know a fat
guy you could make that decision right
now if you want i know but i can't get
fat you could
here's what i actually wanted to ask you
do you think it's weird that we actually
have different very different body types
we're both long and thin in general but
like
we've always had really different body
types you know what's up with that like
i actually thought maybe i'm wrong i
actually mean this sincerely not like in
a dick way i thought you absolutely
could you absolutely could get fat if
you if you wanted to and you can't i
don't think i could get fat i obviously
gained weight dick first of all to say
that i could get fat if i wanted to
uh why are you saying that because i
think you i think you've never seen me
fat even a little bit i know that stop
attacking me i'm not me you're calling
me [ __ ] saying i could be fast see
look how mad you are all right so mom
once said to me yo you're gaining weight
and i i was like 31 and i said no i
remember that you were getting a little
fat no mom talked to me about it
i mean you know no no she didn't ha ha
very funny but um but she was like
you're gaining away because i did a joke
where i lifted up my shirt and she was
like yeah she's like i have a scale
upstairs if you want i went up wow the
most sideways passing an aggressive way
to tell you're fat dude don't just step
on that scale if you want and so i was
like i was like
and so i went upstairs and i put went on
the scale and i gained i was 200 pounds
and i [ __ ] i almost fainted dude
because you were so excited i was like
what the [ __ ] 200 pounds i've always
been
uh 179. that's kind of fat for you 179
not 200. it's not fat i mean i still
look good because i'm a tall drink of
water right yeah i get bigger in all the
right places you know what i mean
uh not if mom was noticing it no i know
no no but well okay yeah i guess i guess
to see what you're saying that wasn't
addicting by the way i wasn't saying
like i have a huge dick no i know that
because i i i could not afford even to
get a more addictable okay well relax
would suck but
mom called you fat dude no she didn't
and so i went and i got onto the scale
and um
i was on the scale and went 200 pounds
and i got really nervous but then my
friend was there and i said hold on to
this i handed him my dick and then it
was back to 179. so it did all go to my
dick your friend held your dick yeah he
held my dick while i was on the scale so
so my dick is 21 pounds it's crazy dude
it's really yeah dude it's crazy but um
so yeah for something the size of a
thimble yes oh dude that's crazy it's
got super suit it's like juggernaut the
x-men so so dork just so much [ __ ]
mass in one
um or ant-man maybe i don't know what it
is but uh the
uh also here's another advice that i
have that's really great don't drink
your calories don't drink [ __ ] coke
don't drink that [ __ ] save the calories
for munching dude save the calories save
the cravings for munching because if
you're having a coke with a meal dude i
stopped drinking soda straight up when i
stopped drinking soda i lost 20 pounds
baron von munchen you heard it here
first okay so
save the calories for when you're baron
von munchen and what was the first one
only do it when you only eat [ __ ] when
you're craving it yeah and then also uh
only eat bad food when you're craving it
and then also stick to a routine when
you work out do it every time at the
same day every every day at the same
time the other thing about me when i
find when the worm finally turns and i
can actually get fat
not only am i gonna get fat because i
have the worst [ __ ] eating habits you
do yeah okay relax no and uh
also i'm everyone who's ever been who's
been in my life for a long period of
time is gonna be so happy that i got fat
why because everyone that i've ever been
around that's been close enough to they
say why something has always been
represented you yeah yeah so mad at me
for being stupid how can you eat like
that why do you [ __ ] like how why
don't you ever gain weight like how
could you put that in your body at this
hour yeah and you know i'm just dildos
dildos wow oh wow
wow so
but how can you put how did you put that
in your body at this hour it's 8 a.m you
put a dildo in your butt yeah um yeah
yeah oh so um
what do you eat you eat pizza pizza i
drink soda oh you do uh i drink i drink
soda i eat pizza okay i eat i eat bread
and sandwiches i eat [ __ ] uh i eat
cookies like a [ __ ] really eat
cookies like the cookie monster wow oh
dude you know what i eat lately what i
eat ice cream sandwiches so good i eat
[ __ ] biscottis
morning afternoon and night really i eat
[ __ ] uh uh noodles noodles all the
[ __ ] really never eats what are the
good things you eat uh never eat salad
nothing i don't eat anything that's good
i say brendan schaub i said how much
water are you drinking i don't drink
water i said you don't drink water
that's weird he was like no i drink a
ton of water he said doesn't taste like
anything i was like yeah but that's not
the point he's like only coffee some
flavored drinks and uh yeah and then
alcohol no water the reason for not
drinking water is because it doesn't
taste like anything that's the plus of
water
the plus of water yeah the plus of water
the plus of water starting kate
blanchett obviously dude the new avatar
movie is cut is called the way of water
bruce lee named it
dude so
[ __ ] get over yourselves
avatar the way of water they're also
is that what you're saying yeah no i'm
saying avatar is so played out now
like you missed the [ __ ] boat with
that one yeah don't make that ship has
sailed but also don't make a sequel 20
years later nautical references back to
back how do you feel about that the way
of watching anyway yes but also don't
make a sequel
20 years later unless it's to a movie
that bombed then i'll i'll watch it yeah
james bio dumb [ __ ] too his whole
life has made huge hits out of movies
that i'm always like why the [ __ ]
would someone make this movie titanic
and avatar both i was like those movies
are gonna [ __ ] bomb who gives this
[ __ ] then not only
did titanic become the highest grossing
movie of all time
then avatar did i know crazy
that guy i i it's like a magic mind i
know how about when um
avatar when they stick their [ __ ]
it's so sexual when they stick their
parts in the [ __ ] flying people and
then the flight you got to stick their
[ __ ] and the flying person's pitching me
the movie james so there's blue people
right uh the roman around the world they
got to find the person to get on the
back so they can fly and then they got
to sync with them and they do that by
sticking their [ __ ] and they're uh
they're flying [ __ ] sounds great do
we have a deal
sounds good man i'd like to thank the
academy
remember when he won top of the world
might was the most
this this was just uh
this
just came from an idea that i had about
sticking [ __ ] and flying [ __ ]
what the hell
the [ __ ] and [ __ ] cards and [ __ ]
the 53rd annual
john malkovich coming up next to present
the award for best guy with accent in
1780 for some reason can't stop thinking
about john malkovich
yeah
do you have spent a lot of your life
talking about john malkovich unprompted
yes i have have you thought about that
it's a funny guy to go to
why do you think about him so much greg
kittier too
why him it's a funny guy to go to funny
guy to go to when you got something
funny
and you need to say an actor that's
annoying
whatever i have to do sometimes i do a
gif gift givings if i never did you do a
joke about gift giving i made you a
sundial it's funny i log it oh what'd
you get me i made your son dial that's
funny i don't know
i don't know either i log them up dude
what does that mean
like what's the like you know you log
them up yeah log them up what does that
mean
ask me what what's a [ __ ] funny song
one headlight by the [ __ ] wall uh
what's a funny song well one headlight
by the [ __ ] one headline like if you
ever need to go to it okay so that was a
joke that's logging him up yeah somebody
you're hanging out with a friend and
somebody's like yeah and then a montage
happens and then you just do one
headlight i get a [ __ ] laugh i just
[ __ ] log them up you lock them up
okay the toys care bear teddy ruxpin
that's where the funny thing is logging
them up i log them up dude what is that
it's like the freestyling of joking like
how eminem is like
it's like how eminem is like nothing
rhymes with orange really what about
orange i've seen that too that's cool
there you go dude yeah he knows what
rhymes and i [ __ ] have teddy ruxpin
in one headlight in my [ __ ]
am i stored in my pentium pentium
there's another one computer if you want
to pick a funny one use that or dell
remember that guy dude i'm getting adele
i got it all stored yeah dude i got all
stories wait funny this ain't apple uh
yes dude
wow
ron stewart the way you said
that was that's a good one too wow
what words did you just say
started my pen no after that that's a
good one too rod stewart funny one
better one phil collins you know what
i'm saying if you want to pick a guy
well i'm just saying i got it all stored
in my pictures sounded like rod stewart
not phil collins i know i know i know
but i'm just saying if we're doing the
thing that i was just talking about
anyway dude
uh i'm gonna be in atlanta
boston cheyenne
uh all sorts of places uh denver um
peoria illinois
jacksonville go to chrisleya.com check
out them dates washington dc so uh also
check out my podcast congratulations and
also give advice to the people in the uh
comments below
you guys are great um if you have a
question send in a video and link it
this uh listen in the video the link is
in the description below or go to
watchlifeline.com thank you very much
leave a comment and subscribe to our
pages well just this page thank you very
much thank you
hello
[Music]